[Applause]
[Music]
just
oh
aretha franklin beyonce deangelo
john legend anderson pack what do they
all have in common
like countless other black musicians
they've all gained their foundation and
love for music
through the black church and the music
at birthed gospel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's sunday and i'm going to church i'm
in orlando florida
at live church where grammy-winning
artist and gospel music star ty tribbett
leads the congregation
the mainstream secular gospel everybody
seems to come through the church
to like hone their gifts you know
because that's the place where a lot of
people are accepted
you can make mistakes and not because
you're not on tv reading charts
you're just like trying to figure it out
[Applause]
so many musicians that i know literally
came through
ga and soundcheck actually that we see
now
[Music]
music in the church is uh unconventional
and
like i said it's not chartered you can
kind of like try things and it'll be
like
weird but it's it's okay with the base
there
okay in the church you can make those
mistakes that'll turn out to be genius
in another field
la and i are in chicago where the work
of gospel pioneers like thomas dorsey
and mahalia jackson gave rise to what we
know as gospel music
but the city doesn't only hold gospel
music's past chicago gospel musicians
are constantly pushing this great art
form
and their skills forward it definitely
chicago is the home for gospel
hands down okay so we're in the right
spot yeah so talk about the
the church the black church being a
training ground for musicians
it's a training ground but also too
everyone is so
on top of their skill and not really
know the raw skill is so great
that it's like singing at the apollo
what's his name
[Music]
you have to be good like you don't have
a choice
or else you just don't get up there you
know so that's why some of the great
singers like an aretha are like with me
or like so many came out
because we hear it all the time and it's
others that you haven't heard that
probably equally it is good that you
will never dream
i think the musicians of this time are
so
skilled like they're incredibly skilled
their ears are not the same
but their ability is like out of work it
really is out of here
really is that i was some y'all make it
too complicated
yeah i think you're over obviously
you're overthinking it's not that it's
not that complicated it's really just
you know two three six five five then
back to one but you're trying to make
you're like
a thirteenth and then trying to expand
it too much i was like it's not that
complicated
[Music]
right there let me show you what they
were doing in in in church now
the melody is all that is within me
instead of going to this yeah instead of
going to that six
right
[Music]
exactly next quarter that the quarters
this is right that's it that's the
sweetness
so who created black gospel music many
historians will tell you it was thomas a
dorsey
he's now regarded as the father of black
gospel music
but dorsey's career didn't start out in
the church born in georgia
dorsey began as a blues musician and
went by the name georgia tom
he toured alongside blues legend ma
rainey and wrote hundreds of blues and
jazz songs
some were a little risque like the hit
he wrote with guitar's tampa red
it's tight like that from 1928.
in the 1920s dorsey had an epiphany he
began to turn away from secular music
and started writing gospel songs
but he didn't leave his past behind he
often infused his gospel music
with the feel and structure of the blues
his gospel song if you see my savior
is swung and upbeat it follows a 16 bar
blues chord progression
and has a steady 4-4 time signature that
you can easily stomp your feet to his
lyrics however
are more hopeful and uplifting than most
blues songs dorsey is offering a
touching send-off to someone who's about
to depart to the other side
[Music]
in 1932 dorsey came here to pilgrim
baptist church in chicago
where he served as music director for
more than 40 years
in 2006 this historic church building
was gutted by fire
and the whole congregation moved across
the street
[Music]
that's uh one of the things that made
professor dorsey
famous today he combined
[Music]
the blues and church music
and gave it that rhythm and swing
that a lot of people weren't ready for
it
dorsey also employs call and response in
many of his songs
an element in african music where one
phrase is the call
and a different phrase is the answer
like in this song never turn back
[Music]
response is historical from slavery
times
because blacks could not read at that
time and
there was always one person around who
could
and they would read it and
everyone else would repeat it behind
them in the morning
when i rise or i'm gonna lay down my
burdens
down by the riverside calling response
is integral to gospel music and can be
found in secular music as well
from artists like james brown to
kendrick lamar sit down
[Music]
also in 1932 dorsey lost his wife and
son during childbirth
this tragedy led him to write what is
considered one of the greatest gospel
songs ever written
take my hand precious lord
unlike if you meet my savior precious
lord maintains the emotion of the blues
without adhering to its structure
check out dorsey himself performing the
song in the 1998 documentary
the story of gospel music
[Music]
[Music]
just to see him we stood in all of him i
know that was history
however dorsey was not always celebrated
professor dorsey came
actually from ebenezer baptist church
where he started
but they did not allow him to do
his music the way he wanted to do it so
he left there
and it came to pilgrim he faced
opposition for blending blues and gospel
with some ministers calling it the
devil's music
a lot of the old-time church folks were
saying that he was playing the devil's
music
that it wasn't of god well i mean
you can liken it until today when we're
doing
hip-hop in church you know a lot of
people's
old people say oh that's our government
no
it's just a new style
[Music]
that's come to us to give the lord
[Music]
praise let's stand for prayer
okay god god we thank you
okay we're ready to finish our man
[Music]
as far as the blending of genres some
people feel like it waters down
the gospel message message is words and
sound is sound
so i don't understand how you can take a
message down with sound
i think more so religion does that
versus spirituality or even god because
when god made music he didn't say
this base part is secular and this place
as part of the gospel we did that
blending gospel and secular sounds
hasn't stopped pioneers like andre
crouch
and kirk franklin have been mixing
gospel with everything from
funk to rock to hip hop
it's this cross-pollination of genres
that makes gospel music so adaptable to
the times
and why gospel musicians are so
versatile we play it all
can you speak on how your church has
embraced this new wave
of music the uh the shared exchange
between
gospel music and secular music is an
exchange of
influence
it's like how my music is outside of the
church i think it's a little bit for
everybody
i think uh the biggest problem i had
even at sony records was
what category do we put this guy in is
this is
is it hip-hop gospel is that so we just
coined this phrase kingdom
we didn't want to music anybody and we
didn't want to be we didn't want to
become elitist either
it's very very broad you can get old
school tambourine chicken eating food
yeah when you get a real song worship
film you just honor the lord you know
what i'm saying this
or we could get straight street we
embrace
all forms of music so we can reach all
forms of people with one message
indeed i came from
the shed jam session thing i just had
like sheds
jam sessions at the house all the time
and from those
some from those pieces of
grooves that we locked into i write
songs like no way came from a shed group
[Music]
okay
come on man come on the term wood
shedding gained popularity among jazz
musicians in the 1930s
it means to go someplace like behind the
woodshed to practice your skills where
no one else can hear
but in the early 2000s shedding became
something new thanks to gerald forrest
the creator of a website called gospel
chops originally
the website was going to focus on church
organists and pianists
but forest shifted its focus to drummers
after he uploaded a video of eric moore
breaking down what was arguably the
first ever documented gospel child
in the mid-2000s gospel chops became a
phenomenon
tony and thomas shed is arguably one of
the most memorable sheds of all time
here one can see those integral parts of
gospel music tony and thomas are
responding to each other's rhythmic
calls
and doing so on the spot
so a question for both of you basically
i've never been to a shed session
i'm not really sure i've since learned
about it but i
i don't know what what to expect what
can i
it'll be i'll have the click tracks
running on the npc app oh cool oh wow
i'm going to blast it through the
monitors wow so
everybody can hear it that's cool and
that's that's happening at seven tonight
eight we'll get there at eight but um
how many people are coming
i'm hoping i'm making a party oh
for gospel drummers like myself nothing
sharpens skills more than shedding
this is how shedding works there are two
simple rules one you establish the
groove
and two trade solos while keeping the
one or the downbeat
locking in the groove is an important
step in shedding because it gives
context to all of the chops
licks and fills the groove is the
template that we all work within
and it allows the trading of solos to
make sense
depending on the tempo of the groove
drummers will solo for either four or
eight bars
four bars for slower tempos eight bars
for faster tempos
[Music]
what started as musicians jamming after
church services
turned into a safe haven for young black
[Music]
musicians
this adaptability continues to push
gospel music into new musical territory
[Music]
and in churches all across the country
the next generation of musicians are
shedding their skills
just look at justin wilson ii better
known as the drumming prodigy baby boy
drummer on instagram
[Music]
here he plays alongside notable gospel
musicians robert bubby lewis
and justin raines at the 2019 nam
convention
the young drummer holds his own
alongside the other musicians in what is
essentially a shed session
the exchange is a testament to the black
gospel church as a training ground for
artists and musicians
what gospel music is and sounds like
continues to change
but there's no denying that the black
gospel church provides a foundation for
future musicians who will one day
share their gifts with the world
but the gospel music industry i i just i
mean
it's so open it could be anything now i
like that it's not just choir robes now
it's so vast because
everybody's not just exposed to their
lane everybody's exposed to everything
[Music]
so there must be a culture of working
extremely hard to get to that level
surrounding this community right i don't
even know if it's work to get there i
think that because that's all you hear
it just shows up it's the
yeah you're around those church services
every day of the week yeah like if you
hear somebody speaking another language
all of your life then you
[Music]
it's just a part of the community so you
just do it you know
just learn how to dance because
everybody's dancing it's the norm it's
the norm
it's very much a normal